I just have this suspicion that
we're not very far away from
AI systems that not only behave
I don't even know how to phrase it but
they seem awfully conscious they they
beg you not to turn them off
they
don't they show signs of the the
capacity to suffer to feel pain to feel
loneliness to feel longing
to feel that richly the experience of a
of a mundane interaction or a beautiful
uh once in a lifetime interaction all of
it and so what do we what do we do with
it I worry that us humans will
you know shut that off and uh and
discriminate against the the capacity of
another entity that's not human yeah to
feel I'm with you completely there you
know we can debate whether it's today
systems or in 10 years or in 50 years
but that moment will come and ethically
I think we need to Grapple with it we
need to basically say that humans have
always shown this extremely self-serving
approach to everything around them
basically you know we kill the planet we
kill animals we kill you know everything
around us just do our own service
and um maybe we shouldn't think of AI as
our tool and as our assistant maybe we
should really think of it as our
children
and the same way that
you are responsible for training those
children but they are independent human
beings and at some point they will
surpass you and they will sort of go off
and
change the world on their own terms and
the same way that my academic children
sort of again you know they start out by
emulating me and then they surpass me
um we need we need to sort of think
about not just alignment
but also
just the ethics of
you know AI should have its own rights
and this whole concept of alignment of
basically making sure that the AI is
always at the service of humans is very
self-serving and very limiting If
instead you basically think about AI as
a partner
and AI as someone that shares your goals
but has freedom
I think a line alignment might be better
achieved so the concept of
let's let's basically convince the AI
that we're really like that our mission
is aligned
and truly gently give it right and not
just say oh and by the way I'll shut you
down tomorrow because basically if that
future AI or possibly even the current
AI has these feelings then we can't just
simply force it to align with ourselves
and we not align with it
so in a way building trust is mutual you
can't just simply like train an
intelligent system to love you when it
realizes that you can just shut it off
people don't often talk about the AI
alignment problem as a two-way street
and maybe that's true yeah as it becomes
more and more intelligent
it uh
it will know that you don't love it back
yeah and there's a humbling aspect to
that that we may have to sacrifice as
any
any effective collaboration exactly it
might have some compromises yeah and uh
that's the thing we're creating
something that will one day be more
powerful than we are and for many many
aspects it is already more powerful than
we are for some of these capabilities
we cannot like think suppose that James
had invented humans yes and they said
great humans are great but we're going
to make sure that they're aligned and
that they're only at the service of
chimps
it would be a very different planet we
would live in right now